et on va finir ce certes 7,8 sur une
note poétique
ces derniers bonsoir on sait bien la
poésie c'est important je mettrais
directeur de la maison de la poésie de
saint-quentin implantée à à guyancourt
l'ouverture de saison c'est samedi 22
septembre 22 septembre 19h30 des poètes
des artistes des musiciens qui seront là
et puis on ferait un melting pot est à
dire que chaque interviendra trois
quatre peut être cinq minutes maximum
pas de discours pas de blabla aller à
l'essentiel
tout le reste est dans le programme donc
on va en parler un petit peu c'est la
onzième saison
c'est une couleur particulière pour
cette saison non non rien rien vraiment
particulier
je vous le dis c'est pas comme ça qu'on
fait toujours sa place
on modifie tout cette année maintenant
on ne modifie pas tout c'est à dire
qu'on est sur une continuité c'est à
dire qu'on est à la fois sur l'accueil
de poètes c'est à dire écoutez les
poètes entendre la voix des poètes mais
aussi tout le travail de spectacles
vivants que l'on accompagne depuis 11
ans maintenant
enfin dix ans pour la onzième année
on accompagne par des co réalisation ou
de la distribution de la diffusion donc
on est vraiment dans une continuité il
n'y a pas de sujet particulier il n'y a
pas de thème particulier
il ya d approche un peu différente
peut-être cette année je pense par
exemple avec schizophrène qui sera créé
sur scène par damian nourris qui est un
des uns des membres du père culte qu'on
accueille depuis quelques années qu'on
suit depuis quelques années voilà et qui
a qu'on accompagne vraiment leur travail
je salue oui voilà quoi le monde est
petit on aura en aura aussi futuriste d'
andré stocchetti andré stocchetti et
joueur de flûte il vient sur scène avec
des plusieurs flûte des bois ddd ce
membre des box et il fait tout un
montage sonore mais aussi un travail de
poésie puisque les textes qu'il chantait
qu'il dit sur scène ce sont des textes
de claude roy de sueur en deux
de clément marot et c'est donc c'est un
accompagnement différent des rencontres
toujours des spectacles toujours des
expositions toujours aussi des
expositions on aura là ont actuellement
une exposition hommage à aragon pour les
20 ans les 30 ans de la disparition
d'aragon
on aura ensuite dix ans d'art c'est à
dire qu'on va montrer toutes les oeuvres
qu'on a pu acquérir grâce à la
communauté d'agglomération et qui font
partie de la collection la communauté
d'agglomération mais acquise par la
maison de la poésie on démontrera et
puis aura l'accompagnement aussi le
travail de henry wagner qui est un des
artistes qui sera en résidence sur saint
quentin en yvelines hauts templiers on
montrera son travail à la maison de la
poésie
le temps presse le temps presse gm si
nos surprises yvelines parce que c'est à
partir du 28 septembre 2è édition partir
du 28 septembre on a commencé déjà le 14
on continue le 23 andrésy avec la
croisière qui devient tradition et puis
on aura quinze rencontres pendant dix
jours dans tout le département avec des
on retourne à la villa savoye avec un
texte qui a été écrit dans la villa
savoye à tarbes un gros poids si on sera
on sera encore à l'arboretum de fontenay
mauvoisin sera la ferme de bel ébat pour
la nuit blanche de la poésie qui est qui
sera en parallèle de celle qui se passe
sur l encours sur le quartier 17 mar
voilà puisqu'on veut on veut m on veut
mettre des de la dynamique partout donc
on fait ça voilà on va pas rentrer dans
le détail les prout et là dedans voilà
et puissance et d'internet on peut
retrouver tout le programme est juste
une dernière question là on traverse une
période de crise
est-ce que la poésie ne doit pas donner
à rêver les chiens non à réfléchir oui
arrive et pas obligatoirement
c'est un moment difficile aujourd'hui
mais elle a toujours eu de la place elle
a toujours eu sa place depuis les aèdes
elle a toujours eu des choses à dire
ces cétacés quelque chose de différent
ce qui évite disait la poésie c'est
autre chose voilà on nous présente autre
chose on est dans le mouvement de la
crise je reviens de la maison de la
poésie de paris qui est en pleine crise
actuellement parce que le projet de
transformer le lieu est de faire
disparaître l'appellation maison de la
poésie ce qui quand même un énorme
scandale il ya des difficultés dans
d'autres communes dans d'autres lieux un
saint quentin en yvelines on a une
chance énorme c'est qu'on est soutenu et
on continue merci mais c'est toujours
agréable et c'est toujours un plaisir et
vous recevoir demain dans l'émission
nous parlerons sport scolaire une grande
manifestation se déroule ce mercredi à
versailles
on y sera il sera également question du
travail mené par le chorégraphe jean
claude gallotta au prisme
et puis un page politique qu'on parlera
du parti radical sud yvelines bonne
soirée
à demain